are you where you planned to be right
now for filmmaking with your career am I
where I plan to be I think I always am
in my younger years always saw myself as
a writer director because that to me was
like the total creator where's the
directors trust the translator of
someone else's inspiration so no I'm not
I'm not where I saw myself or wished
myself or even wishing myself right now
just that writing is so hard and I've
such respect for writers that do that to
themselves and the the stakes of that of
you working on something for years that
then might or might not get made or
might or might not even turn out well
it's kind of more than I can I can bear
with my fragile creative ego so I'm kind
of playing it safe by staying in the in
the directing world which I probably
should thinking about it now I probably
should write again and try try more of
that because I think that that
fulfillment that you get from seeing
your story not just the way it's told on
screen but your story from from the
first seed is something that might must
be spectacular but I've only had was my
very first movie ever where I hadn't
even written the script but it was a
found footage thing that just came to be
but to know that these characters would
not exist without me having had the idea
for them was incredible and I haven't
had that since because these characters
that I know bring to life they are
already jumping off the page and just
putting them on the screen so they would
exist in some other incarnation one way
or the other it's organic expected from
me being that a writer being the real
creative driving force behind any
storytelling and then the format is just
what the director is involved I think um
it's also the turbulence it goes along
with right and I was watching a
documentary that compared on Dashiell
Hammett and Raymond Chandler and their
lives Oh their lives had been you know
turbulent for different reasons but it
it was very maybe the turbulence of the
writing contributed to the the depth of
the stories right
you know and
with directing some of that you like you
said you're taking other people's maybe
even turbulence and you're bringing it
to life but you don't have to
necessarily experience all that I'm yeah
and the risk you don't take the risk of
just wasting a lot of time you know if I
if I get sent a script and it's financed
then I know the time that I spend on it
right now will translate into most of
the time but translate into a finished
product on screen whereas if I sit down
at the computer with a blank page and I
start you know writing scene one day so
and so the chances of that actually
ending up on screen one day are so
miniscule so miniscule which I think you
just have to be either ignorant off to
do it or be completely delusional to do
it anyway at great you know more power
to the people that can do that
I get demotivated I think too quickly if
I hear the numbers some producers said
to me that in their company which
produced a lot back then
they have about eight percent of what
makes it into the final stages of
development that they are really
developing with a full intention of
making it to the screen eight percent of
that makes it to the screen and only a
miniscule percentage of what they start
developing makes it into the final stage
so really someone and I don't want to
demotivate anyone I think any writer it
has to be so driven anyway that the
numbers don't matter and they just write
it because they have to write it because
otherwise it'll tear them apart but if
you did look at the numbers I think you
would you would try to do something
other than start writing a script from
scratch and I know that's exactly where
I'm going wrong and I should find the
courage again to just do it for the
creative alternate and I just haven't in
a couple of years so that's the answer
to do I find myself where I want it to
be no but I also have to earn a living
which would be really hard if I now took
a year or two to write a script and
might or might not ever get me you know
so like real life just kind of kicks in
at some point right right if you look at
a lot of the writers that continually
put their work out there and the
turbulence that went through it you know
maybe it's it's just being more of a
realist yeah
you know just I wonder if realism and
pragmatism is like a big enemy of the
creative spark that you almost have to
fight that as much as you can work
look it straight in the eye and say I
know that I might live under a bridge in
a year because I can't pay my rent but
it doesn't matter because I'd rather
live under a bridge and do creatively
what I was born to do then live in a
cozy apartment and be miserable because
I'm not doing that I think it's either
of those of those two things yeah yeah I
mean if speaking of another or like LA
based writer I know
Dashiell Hammett was in the Bay Area but
you know Charles Bukowski
you know just yes you know brilliant
person but the turbulence they came out
of that and and what comes first the
turbulent sort of mind with amazing
ideas and stories or or the process of
doing something over and over gonna be
rejected and then that brings out the
turkey I don't know right like chicken
or the egg but that's also part of the
pragmatism we're talking about them I'm
I know I'm self-aware enough to know
that I'm not a Kowski that I'm not a
genius with a turbulent story that you
know I'm probably a pretty if you look
at a pretty mediocre writer so factoring
that into my chances of success if I
knew I were a genius writer I would take
the chance but knowing that I'm a
friends there are so much better
writers that don't get anywhere and
really should that it would take a lot
of ego for me to suddenly say you know
what I have to say something to the
world that trumps all that and it's
going to surpass all that I wish I could
tell you something more inspirational
then I'm too afraid to write but at the
moment that's kind of the reason why I
just direct so maybe the inspirational
thing would be if you if you still have
that energy in you and they fight to to
make your story hurt amazing and go for
it I think even with Raymond Chandler
wasn't he fired from his oil job so it
kind of he was in a spot where he was
ready to do it so again it was sort of
like you know life sort of
kind of stripped everything away right
yeah would imagine that's the case for
many people and that's why you see
people with these dual careers you know
that the create creative path presents
itself when the pragmatic real life path
comes to a difficult spot kind of a
thing
you